August 2012 passing high over the
Southern Ocean the worldview-2 satellite
captures an image of a bright pink Lake
something very strange is going on here
the image is of middle island off the
coast of southern Australia the bright
pink patch is a 40 acre body of water
called Lake Hillier I've never seen
anything like this a bubblegum pink Lake
the lake looks toxic the pink color
could be a sign of deadly contaminants
or even unknown life-forms
investigators scrutinize the satellite
image could the vivid color just be an
optical illusion when sunlight reflects
off water it can make it appear shades
of peach or gold this can also happen in
satellite images an optical phenomenon
known as Sun glint sun glints occur when
sunlight reflects off the water at the
same angle as a satellite viewing it
when sunlight hits the water the colours
change but this is always pink
examination of other images of the lake
proves the bright pink color is a
genuinely strange phenomenon in every
image it appears pink this is no optical
illusion historical records reveal the
lakes color is not a new phenomenon
this lake has been pink for some time
even early explorers made notes of the
earliest description of the lake dates
back to 1802
when famous British explorer Matthew
Flinders visited the remote island his
journal records the sighting in the
northeastern part was a small lake of a
rose color the lake has been this color
for at least 200 years if it predates
European colonisation it must be a
natural phenomenon of some kind
naturalist consider the possibility
there's something alive in the lake
causing the vivid pink color water
samples reveal Lake Hillier has a very
high salt content similar to the Dead
Sea this makes it deadly for most living
creatures but not all there is another
way that you can get multicolored water
and that is from microorganisms bacteria
and algae can live in some of the most
inhospitable places on earth so a salty
lake is par for the course there is
something alive in the lake the life
form at the center of the mystery is a
single-celled micro alga called Donna
Lella Selena
donal yella Selena produces a red
pigment that is called a carotenoid
these are the same pigments at growing
carrots here the carotenoids are not
Orange
they're actually pink
you